monchengladbach fondly remember their
glory days of the 70s but now it's time
for new heroes like Patrick Hammond once
touted as the new Marco hoist he's even
put the hurt on Bayern Munich in the
past but lately he spent more time on
the bench Hammond has been with glad
before six years but starting this
season he's been facing some internal
competition from Andrea Hahn who also
plays Hammonds position good you
yourself say you're very ambitious is
your career moving fast enough for you
yeah mush negin whoo kid naf kind father
absolutely not as an athlete you have to
be ambitious to achieve your goals of
course it's hard to reach them right
away do you have to be patient although
that's tough sometimes in the 10th round
you scored two goals and got an assist
against Hoffenheim but the season didn't
start out so well for you you didn't
play it all at the start and then just a
little but now things are going great
again is that typical for you to
business advice of my own it's not
typical but it does reflect the life of
a footballer there are times when things
don't go so well and you just have to
get through it when the season began I
didn't play it all then I got sent on
more and more I played an entire half
against Schalke in those minutes on the
pitch you could see I gave it my all
let's give one want one cos he ever come
on as one inside line if you haven't got
to play for a while does that make you
even more ambitious it seems that way
yeah it's a man having this all come yes
you're really incensed you want to play
no matter what so when you're held back
it's very sobering and tough to tape at
first I hardly played at all but i must
say Andre Han played right wing and did
a great job hun here he scored great
goals and set up great place and you
just have to accept
that most minus off but if you keep at
it and give it your all you'll prevail
Gasca tons it's just off to us I'm a
good note I imagine that's really hard
if someone new joins the team takes over
your position and play as well that must
really get to you that's muslin I'm not
in viewing that noxious it does it's
tough to explain last season I played in
every match yet when the Bundesliga
kicked off again I found myself sitting
for 90 minutes on the bench time and
again now the papers are raving about
both of you together about Han and
Hammond in photos you're seen hugging
one another so is that gratifying to its
own Club it's not use no reason of
hugely gratifying to competitors who
shared a spot at the start of the season
are now playing together and doing it
well we complement one another and can
swap places he goes left and I go right
and that pays off as you saw during the
game against Hoffenheim so even for
professionals the trick is work hard and
be patient the principle is the same you
can't change it at home you're a bit
down and keep asking why you're not
playing are thinking you have to play
home sweet Monday sorta but it's all for
naught as soon as you're on the pitch or
the training field you just have to give
110% and show you want to play not
simple sent game on one side in this
Monday but what do you do when you're
depressed at home yeah just keep mum
it's tough I take the dog for a walk or
watch TV or go to the movies but it's
almost impossible to switch off entirely
that you seem like someone who's never
in a bad mood yeah at home you really
can't stop thinking about things that
you might have been able to get the ball
another way or stuff like that but it
doesn't help you still brood that's
wheel fearful yes I also have sleepless
nights especially after a match that
didn't go so well consistent watched as
her ambitious could you imagine leaving
your club to take the next step up the
career ladder washday that's mundus my
mama says my year in fine for lesson
listen summer foster and often I could
but it's tough to say
I like my team and want to play here as
long as I can but in soccer things can
change so fast that it's hard to know
what will happen in a few years time
when Polly online with us so i can't say
yet can eat your funny stuff on board ok
nothing then I wish you fewer sleepless
nights nice don't feel tension ok lang